[Music]
on this Thursday night an arrest in one
of America's worst security breaches the
young National Guardsmen accused of
leaking classified documents this was a
deliberate criminal act
targeting crit
including in Canada
stopping sex torsion I call it an
epidemic one province's new law to
protect children
and why Mary Quant mattered you know she
just did so much women and and kind of
empowerment a trailblazing British
designer who revolutionized women's
fashion
National with Donna Friesen good evening
and thanks for joining us we begin
tonight with extraordinary scenes of an
arrest in the United States the FBI
moved in on a home in Suburban
Massachusetts arresting a suspect
believed to be behind the leak of a
trove of classified documents that's him
slowly walking backwards with his hands
over his head the Pentagon accuses the
21 year old of a criminal deliberate Act
today the justice department arrested
Jack Douglas deshara in connection with
an investigation into alleged
unauthorized removal retention and
transmission of classified National
Defense information
the defense department has worked for
days to find the source of the leaks
which it calls a serious risk to
National Security they reveal sensitive
secrets about both allies and
adversaries in Russia's war on Ukraine
our Washington bureau chief Jackson
prosco is with me now Jackson what do we
know about the suspect
hi Donna 21 year old Jack Teixeira is a
Technology support staffer for the Air
National Guard at a base on Cape Cod
Thursday he was arrested without
incident by the FBI accused of illegally
sharing classified defense information
the New York Times reports he began
sharing classified documents with a
small online chat group on the platform
Discord now reports suggest at first he
was transcribing documents and then
later he began printing those documents
off and posting photos of those
documents those photos were eventually
posted to a public forum by one of the
chat group's members now the documents
reveal highly sensitive material
including U.S assessments of how the war
in Ukraine is going they also reveal the
depth of U.S infiltration of Russia's
military command the Pentagon is deeply
worried because some of the intelligence
that was leaked was brand new just a few
weeks old we do have stringent
guidelines in place for safeguarding
classified insensitive information this
was a deliberate criminal act a
violation of those guidelines Jackson
they've got one suspect in custody is
there a sense this will plug the leak or
that the Pentagon knows the full extent
of who might be involved
well at this point early reports suggest
Teixeira may have only intended to share
these documents with that smaller group
of online friends but based on the
language we heard used by the U.S
attorney general today he will likely be
facing charges under the Espionage Act
and a decade or more in prison if
convicted in fact each leaked document
could turn out to be its own charge this
is also likely to prompt a broader
review though of access to classified
information across U.S intelligence
agencies and the military it really
raises questions about why low-level
employees should be able to see such
high-value documents it is absolutely
clear at this stage that the U.S
intelligence Community writ large
has to get its house in order this is
just not sustainable no other country is
leaking information at that scale I can
see a number of of areas where reform
could be uh could be at least approached
and considered
it's early but experts suggest this is
among the most damaging and embarrassing
intelligence leaks in U.S history what's
even worse here Donna is that it seems
these leaked documents were online for
nearly a month before the Pentagon
became aware
okay Jackson Prasco in Washington thanks
there was a heads up today from Canada's
cyber security agency the CSE it says
there's been a notable rise especially
in the last few weeks of cyber threat
activity by Russian aligned actors
including malicious cyber activity
directed at critical infrastructure
networks Mackenzie gray is with me from
Ottawa McKenzie do we know who has been
targeted no we don't Donna the head of
the communications security
establishment wouldn't give any
specifics but it's rare for them to even
speak with us about cyber threats and
this was an interesting conversation
they had with us today they did
underscore the fact though that there
hasn't been any of these threats
materializing and there wasn't any key
damage to the infrastructure but they
reiterated that threats posed by foreign
countries and non-state hackers are real
and they say that one of the main
countries they're worried about is
Russia and that country was able to
bring down Hydro Quebec's mobile app and
website earlier this morning through
what's called a denial of service attack
which basically shuts down a website for
a period of time but doesn't take any
sensitive data and hydro Quebec was
quick to underscore that saying their
critical systems weren't affected and no
data or personal info were stolen but
Donna this is just the first of many
Russian cyber attacks recently on
Canadian targets over the past couple of
days they were able to take down the
sites of the port of Quebec Laurentian
Bank and even the prime minister's
website was taken down by a pro-russian
group McKenzie Poland's military
counterintelligence sounded the alarm
today about a widespread Espionage
campaign by Russian intelligence
targeting NATO members and EU countries
what are they warning of yeah they're
trying to draw attention to a pretty
sophisticated phishing scam being run by
the Russians that actually looks fairly
innocent now here's one example it's an
email sent to some Western diplomats
that impersonates a polish Embassy
employee trying to get other countries
diplomats to sign up for an event at the
embassy and if they click on the link or
even add it to their calendar the
Russians can gain access to their
computers and Donna the polls are
warning that this campaign is still
ongoing and the Russians are targeting
foreign Ministries and diplomatic
entities including ones here in Canada
to be on the lookout for Mackenzie gray
in Ottawa thanks
there is a story about privacy
percolating within the Liberal Party the
federal government has signaled it plans
to make political parties subject to
privacy laws right now the collection of
personal information by political
parties is subject almost no rules and
no oversight but in BC the federal
Liberal Party is taking that province's
privacy commissioner to court to prevent
being subject to privacy laws David
Aiken is looking into this Paradox
tonight David
well Donna it was a single line in the
Trudeau government's spring budget right
back here page 254 a promise to
introduce a bill that would make Federal
political parties subject to the same
privacy laws as any other business or
organization in Canada
as it stands now the collection of
personal information at political
rallies or through fundraising or
through online and digital campaigns is
subject to almost no rules and no
oversight parties are free to store
trade or sell that personal information
as they please and they never need the
consent of the individuals whose
information they have BC's privacy
commissioner Michael McAvoy thinks
that's a bad idea our expectation is
that political parties will ensure that
people's personal information is treated
properly and respectfully and legally
McAvoy issued an order that Federal
parties operating in British Columbia
must comply with that province's privacy
protection laws the federal liberals
along with the federal conservatives and
federal new Democrats push back and all
three Federal parties are taking the BC
commissioner to court challenging his
authority the Privacy commissioner's
action was sparked by a complaint from a
retired University Professor Andrew
Clement the Federal political parties
are in inherent conflict of interest
when it comes to legislating their own
behavior the way out of that is to show
that they're not doing any favors
special favors to themselves the Prime
Minister gets the problem one of the
things that we've discovered over over
the past number of years is different
provinces are moving forward with
privacy regimes that do vary from one
region to the next it's going to be
important that we make sure that our
federal electoral system and our federal
rules around political parties are
homogeneous and cohesive but he would
not say when his government will deliver
on that budget promise in the meantime
BC's privacy commissioner and the
federal political parties are set to
face off in court early in May Donna all
right David Aiken in Ottawa thanks in
Alberta and RCMP investigation is
underway after two girls were found dead
in a hotel room in the Town of Sylvan
Lake Police say they were discovered
Sunday morning few details have been
released friends and family say one of
the girls is 13 year old Olivia Dawn
Johnson who was from Red Deer Sarah Reed
is there tonight Sarah are there any
more details
Donna those who knew Olivia Dawn Johnson
say that she was a gift and even after
her passing they say she continues to be
a leader in her community Olivia for
many years was a member of the Red Deer
indigenous dance troupe and this week
they gathered to celebrate her life
through song dance and prayer
on Facebook Olivia's mom says her
daughter
Sunday the same day they brought her
home from the hospital 13 years ago
after she was born RCMP are now
investigating hers and another girl's
deaths after their bodies were found in
a hotel room at the Best Western in
Sylvan Lake Police say there are no
indications that Olivia and the 12 year
old girl from Sylvan Lake took their own
lives or were murdered they say they are
looking into the possibility they died
from a drug overdose but that has yet to
be confirmed RCMP also adds there was a
male parent nearby at the time but would
not provide any more details the medical
examiner's office is working to
determine the cause of death and will be
running a toxicity test in the community
where the tragedy happened people are
finding the news difficult to process
the girl's deaths have deeply impacted
their Community here in Red Deer there's
been an outpouring of support for
Olivia's family and they do plan on
Gathering here next week to celebrate
her life and to say their final goodbyes
Donna all right Sarah Reed in Red Deer
Alberta thanks
there are concerning new details about
serious flaws in Ontario's child welfare
system a damning report by Ontario's
Ombudsman points to a lack of oversight
limited options and questionable care
the report focuses on the case of one
vulnerable indigenous girl who is sent
to Foster Care Homes far from her
Northern Ontario community the 13 year
old with fetal alcohol spectrum disorder
and a history of trauma went missing
seven times while in the care of Johnson
Children's Services once she vanished
for 19 days putting her the report says
at significant risk of human trafficking
she was supposed to get one-on-one
supervision but Johnson Children's
Services failed to protect her from what
the report calls evidence of drugs
physical and sexual assault the report
makes 58 recommendations which have been
accepted our chief investigative
correspondent Carolyn Jarvis is with me
Carolyn has been reporting on Ontario's
child welfare system for more than a
year Carolyn this is a damning report
about one girl what's strikes you the
most
well fundamentally Donna that we have a
system in place that allows this to
happen with little oversight and weak or
delayed consequences for companies that
break the rules this foster care agency
Johnson Children's Services was already
the subject of a scathing investigation
paid for by the province in 2019. that
report looked into foster homes that
operated in the Thunder Bay Area and
exposed serious concerns about the care
it was providing a 17 year old
indigenous girl named Tammy kiosh ran
away from one of those homes and was
found dead the next day The Province
forced Johnson Children's Services to
shut down their foster care homes in the
north but in a stunning move allowed
them to keep operating homes in the
South and so here we are today in a
tragic situation that some say was
preventable I should add we reached
Johnson children's services on the phone
today but they declined to comment The
Province also wouldn't answer our
questions about why it allowed Johnson's
to keep operating in the south
Carolyn your investigative reporting is
focusing on the treatment of indigenous
youth in the child welfare system who
were often sent far from their
communities what does this report say
about that process
well there's a harrowing line where the
Children's Aid Society in the north
which place the 13 year old girl in a
Johnson's foster home admits it was
warned by another agency not to do it
but quote desperation sets in they said
because there are no resources in the
north the Ombudsman Paul Dube
underscored this in an interview with us
today that Northern Communities
especially indigenous communities are at
such a significant disadvantage when it
comes to supports for use in care and
youth who have higher needs that too
frequently they are sent south which is
a form of culture shock that only adds
to their trauma
right Carolyn Jarvis in Toronto tonight
thanks
and a little later we look at how one
province is working to better protect
children and teenagers from sex torsion
that's coming up but first thousands of
First Responders from across the country
were in Pro riviere today for the
funeral of Sergeant Maureen bro she is
the Quebec provincial police officer who
was killed in the line of duty last
month
[Music]
they're always stabbed two weeks ago
while trying to make an arrest the 42
year old was a veteran officer with more
than 20 years experience
these men and women
despite their education
despite their commitment
our first and over most and foremost
human beings
who are subjected to difficult
dangerous and sometimes Federal
conditions
bro was the eighth police officer to die
on the job in Canada in the last six
months
more than a foot of rain in Florida's
South coming up the rescues and the
record-breaking rain wreaking havoc
all right I'm gonna go back and get your
mommy and daddy all right Bud dozens of
people had to be rescued in South
Florida and several flood emergencies
remain in effect there tonight A Fierce
and slow-moving spring storm produced
supercell thunderstorms and torrential
rain more than 50 centimeters of rain
fell over Fort Lauderdale that City's
rainiest day in history even the airport
is flooded all flights in and out of
Fort Lauderdale's International Airport
are canceled until tomorrow
former U.S president Donald Trump was
back in New York City today for a second
deposition in a 250 million dollar civil
fraud case Trump was questioned under
oath in the lawsuit brought by the
state's attorney general it accuses
Trump his family business and three of
his children of overstating the value of
assets by billions of dollars to get tax
benefits and preferential loans it is a
high stakes case that threatens the
operation of Trump's business Empire in
the New York State he denies any
wrongdoing last week Trump was in New
York to plead not guilty to 34 felony
counts stemming from hush money payments
to an adult film star the U.S justice
department will take the fight over
access to a widely used abortion pill to
the Supreme Court late yesterday a
federal appeals court imposed several
barriers to accessing the medication it
bars sending it through the mail being
prescribed by health care providers who
are not doctors and excludes use by
those more than seven weeks pregnant the
U.S justice department says it strongly
disagrees with the decision and wants to
protect Americans access to safe and
effective reproductive care the pill is
the most common method of ending
pregnancies in the U.S
still ahead one province's attempt to
better protect children and teens from
sex torsion
[Music]
sexual extortion is on the rise and how
to go after those who share intimate
images of others without their consent
is a huge problem people of all ages can
be exploited but often the victims are
children and teenagers and increasingly
young boys need to garcha reports on
what's being done in one Province to
better protect children from online
exploitation
Jean-Marie hatung says she was just 14
when intimate images of her were posted
online without her consent being afraid
to open my phone and answer an email or
go onto Instagram the now 19 year old
international student at Dalhousie
University says she's studying to become
a lawyer in Canada and wants to support
other victims with similar experiences
it has made me a stronger person being
able to now talk about it and being able
to now reach out and tell people what
had happened as long as nobody talks
about it it continues Surrey BC high
school social justice teacher Annie
Ohana says about once a month a student
comes to her saying they're experiencing
some kind of violence online you see
kids sharing devices you see kids
sharing images like you know everybody
knows this so first of all no judgment
so how do you incorporate this into your
curriculum I start with that idea of
respect and consent are we really giving
them the the skill set to know what red
flags there are but also then and let's
say something is happening how to report
it early and often in response to
tragedies like Amanda Todd who was 15
when she died by suicide after years of
sex extortion BC's government recently
passed what it calls the intimate images
protection act so the whole design of it
is to be an online portal that's 24 7 24
hours a day on your phone you can make
an application to the Civil resolution
tribunal the perpetrator to actually be
given an order to say take it down
statistics Canada says there was a
nearly 80 percent increase in
cyber-related extortion offenses in 2020
from the year before the Canadian Center
for Child Protection says that number
continues to rise oh I'd call it an
epidemic the situation is completely out
of control we we can barely keep up the
center says many cases are Money
Motivated and there's a spike in boys
being targeted they're tricked into
believing they're speaking with a
teenage girl they do something sexual
it's recorded on the other side and then
the threats ensue it's okay it happens
you are here now and we can help you
Jean-Marie is encouraging other victims
to reach out for help saying it was
support from loved ones and years of
therapy that's helped her walk away from
living in constant fear
Global News Vancouver
inspiring and influential next the
impact of fashion designer Mary Quant
[Music]
the Fashion World lost a Trailblazer
today British designer Mary quandt has
died at the age of 93. she grew up with
austerity during the war and in the
1960s decided to transform the way women
dress ditching the corseted often demure
look of her mother's generation and
focusing on fun frivolity and women's
Liberation Eric Sorensen explains why
Mary Quant mattered
[Music]
it was a new era called The Swinging 60s
and fashion designer Mary Quant was not
only at the center of it she helped
create it Quant made a daring break from
conservative and corseted women's
Fashions turning long skirts into mini
skirts a taste may be a bit outlandish
for some but she certainly got a flair
for with it clothes for wivid goes Quant
added color and fun styles that made
Twiggy famous and exported the hip
London culture that transformed how
women around the world wanted to dress
and be seen she believes that girls were
made to be looked at not covered up one
started to get this independent outgoing
very young very alive look that came in
in the 60s and they expressed all the
Emancipation that was
about to to happen then even quant's bob
haircut by Vidal Sassoon was Trend
setting a recent documentary captured
her philosophy don't be boring the point
of clothes should be one that you'll
notice two that you look sexy and three
that you feel good conservative Society
didn't like it I can't say that
particularly approve of some of the
stars but Quant was undaunted she bought
rolls of fabric constantly experimented
and believed in Mass producing fashions
that would help liberate women her
Legacy is the beginning of swinging
London the real swing in London and how
we remember it the sexualized Styles and
presentation can still shock but Quant
was a Pioneer unleashing a sense of
freedom for women to dress and to be
however they wanted you know she just
did so much women and and kind of
empowerment
so you know she changed the way women
were in society I feel some of her
Styles look out of step with today's
Trends but it was Mary quant's
groundbreaking fashions that pushed back
against the repressive treatment of
women half a century ago
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your candidate is this foggy forest in
North Vancouver BC thanks for watching
for our nazare will be at the anchor
desk tomorrow and I'll see you Saturday
for the new reality bye-bye
foreign
[Music]